paul
on commence par la piscine mais c'est
pourquoi loin déjà pour arriver à la
piscine l'aveyron km ouais c'est ça qui
l'a ensuite la machine au vaincu le tir
à l'arc
ensuite les aliens pour la barre ensuite
on va faire
le danemark pour le vélo course à des
gallois l'a concédé l'eau propre et la
schl a la charge l'achat chelem et
l'introduit en assurer la concertation
et mais ensuite on revient c'est de dire
que ce gars pour une touffe bertoua été
lâchés à partir de lundi on va revenir
au sein de l'union
sa soirée m brasse 5e
e
c'est sympa une heure à une heure et
demie d'efforts en fonction du niveau et
de l'implication un mégot de prouver
qu'un équipes qui sont forts j'aime bien
les gagnants
lemagit ça fait bien sûr
en confiant un peu mais à samia ben
j'aime bien parce que moins on le
rencontre baba de nouveaux collégiens on
peut leur on peut devenir à nous des
choses comme plongeur donc c'est bien on
a bien agi
ça fait du bien en surimpression
maintenant
là on va refaire
çà et là tu te tient la corde selon lui
tire dessus tu tires et ben voilà tiens
m
hier
c
ouais
ce n'est pas un peu fan de l'idée
c'était ça c'est que les gamins et
surtout avec un une épreuve fun c'est
pas là où on fera les différences au
niveau du classement et qu'ils aient un
bon souvenir donc d'idc qui font que ça
descende axway décembre donc il ya
quatre ateliers tyrolienne les élèves
font une slackline sur une dizaine de
mètres avec une petite aide pour
progresser il s'accroche sur la
tyrolienne ensuite ils descendent et il
enchaîne sur le reste des épreuves donc
c'est intégré dans le raid
et voilà ça leur met un peu de stress
pour certains et beaucoup de plaisir
pour la majorité
surtout la qualité de nos paysages nos
travers des activités en finalisation
liés à l'activité mais aussi à tout ce
qui est à côté on sécurise les déchets
la nutrition tout ce qui touche
l'activité physique dans la nature
avec les élèves du nss on profite du
regroupement fait pour pouvoir les
sensibiliser sur la gestion des déchets
au quotidien donc le tri des déchets les
bacs jaunes et des déchets trouve
aujourd'hui un foyer animalière du
directoire et on travaille également
presque un petit roux donc une brigade
verne pour aider les élèves à les
accompagner par un déchet qui restait
sur le site
à la sortie des élèves